i am such a huge fan of the show my kids
and i watch the show and i think they've
watched it now twice
they love you matteo is the best you
know i mean
for you to know that people are
absolutely absorbing this show and it's
coming to end
has that kind of kind of reflected on
you right now that it's coming to an end
honestly i it hasn't
um you know normally we have such an
easy schedule filming the show
but um the last two episodes we had to
film
and work um 12 13 days
straight uh including the weekends we
did night shoots
so right now um i'm more the only thing
i'm feeling is exhaustion
um it hasn't hit me yet i think
definitely
like it'll hit me like a week from now
i'll just be like grocery shopping and
just
start breaking down in the middle of
whole foods or something i know you're
gonna have that moment right yeah
yeah and you talked about the fact that
you shot the last two episodes
what kind of journey will fans go
through is it going to be very emotional
uh it's going to be emotional i think
fans are going to be really happy with
the way things
wrap up especially for mateo's um
whole uh arc of you know as we know
mateo is
undocumented and you know we really
wanted to bring a conclusion to his
story while
staying true to what um you know people
who are undocumented what they go
through you know we didn't want to do
like a
just like a magic wand that will just
fix all these problems because that you
know would be a disservice to
undocumented immigrants and their whole
experience so we want to stay true to
what he was going through but still sort
of give him that that happy ending
that he deserves and that's what's so
special about the show is the fact that
you take real issues and make it
conversational
bring a comedic aspect to it do you have
a chance to give your input through the
seasons you were
able to say you know let's do the story
this way or this way
you know it's a very collaborative
process um
thank god that that it is that they're
always open to our feedback
we always have discussion on you know
like every time we read an episode if
you have any thoughts about
about that particular episode they're
always open to hearing our thoughts
about it
you know um so we've been really lucky
in that regard you know
um other shows um
don't have that kind of freedom so
what's your favorite storyline
um well i always like it but mateo has
like you know
um a boyfriend or a love life it's so
nice to be able to portray a gay
character on screen that that has that
you know um
i think you know early on like back in
the 90s or whatever like whenever they
would introduce a gay character it was
like a castrated person that never
dated anybody or never had any sort of
like social life and
to be able to portray a gay character
who is just like
living his best life and being as normal
as he
as he can be and doing all the things
that his straight counterparts are doing
um is great what has this character
meant for you in your career to be able
to bring it to life the way you just
explained but like it's just
it's beautiful it's it's been amazing i
never thought i would have
the the opportunity to sort of portray
um
a character so close to my own
experience being being gay and being an
immigrant and being filipino
um you know when i first started out in
this industry i was trying out for like
all sorts of like asian parts they were
just like you're asian
you're kind of like sort of like
racially ambiguous it could be chinese
like they see my last name they're like
oh santos are you latino that's
you know throwing it in for for latino
parts i mean like mateo was originally
written as
as a as a straight latino guy so i'm not
sure if that's why they're brought up oh
i didn't know that
wow yeah he was he was originally a
straight latino guy like
super like i mean like the straightest
latino guy
you could even imagine and and i went in
for the audition and i was kind of just
like well i know this person i've worked
with somebody like this before
i kind of modeled him after all the
shady queens i used to work with in
retail
and they they went for it and really
liked my interpretation and they
they changed character on because of my
audition that's crazy
i didn't know that that's amazing what
would you miss most about this show
um the people the people that i work
that i work with i mean not just the
cast but the crew
like you know a lot of the crew's also
been with us from the very beginning
um you know the cast has become my
family
um and you know i don't i don't say i
know people say that all the time oh
we're like a family but we really are
like a family like
i don't know it's we've gotten so close
and i think
yeah it's just not being able to sort of
walk in every day at work and and seeing
their their faces and and how we just
make each other laugh every day and like
i'm gonna miss that song oh
and america ferrera she left earlier in
the season what was it like saying bye
to her character
i mean you had a moment to say bye to
something right like was that hard
it was hard but also like because we we
ended season five
you know during the pandemic we had to
shut down um
so she had to come back at the top of
the uh
of season six to wrap up that story so
we can't have like these this two
two-parter goodbye with her
so um yeah it's it's always hard to
you know say goodbye to to a friend who
you worked with for a long time and
yeah and then you know she was
definitely a key part of the show but um
i i think um yeah we was just
i know i hate goodbyes you know wait is
she gonna be part of the second the last
two episodes
i mean i don't know i can't tell wink
or do something or
shake your head she is she's gonna be
part of it isn't she
what i didn't say that
[Laughter]
you're not getting i think so hey i'm
looking forward to it
uh you know this this show has spoke to
so many people
so many different levels uh with the
storylines were there
any story lines you thought i'm
surprised we're actually going there
no i'm not like from the beginning we've
always tackled like
um current events and and things that
i've always been in the news
it's what our show does best you know
like we tackle
hard-hitting topics um in a very
insightful and
and in a very funny way so anything that
they
they threw on the table we're just like
of of course we're tackling that um
i know i i it's one of the things i love
the most about the show is that we're
able to do that
and apparently there may be a spin-off
right bo and cheyenne
yes bo and cheyenne i believe the script
is currently um
under development so you know like
listen it's going to be shatteo forever
i love
cheyenne and matteo's um friendship
so um i don't know hopefully like they
asked me to be a guest sarcasm
are you gonna be showing up yeah i think
you will i hope so i hope so
like i again you know i i love nicole
um dearly and and johnny pemberton who
plays beau um
he's wonderful so like any time they
if they even ask me to like even be like
an extra on it like i would jump at the
chance
i love that and any updates on crazy
rich asians
nothing girl nothing nothing i haven't
heard anything yet so
i i mean it's hard listen we're we are
in the middle of a pandemic and i know
people are starting to shoot movies
again but um
yeah i haven't i haven't heard anything
on that front again
i i'm dying to know because i i would
love that
that is one reunion that i can't wait
for is to be reinvited with my crazy
mutations cast
how would you just describe superstore
and the experience
ah magical and amazing and a dream
that's something that you know like i
never thought would ever happen in my
life
um and i really don't think you know i
don't know what the future holds for me
but
um i don't know i i don't know if i'm
ever going to get it this good
like i really lucked out on this one and
it was such an amazing experience and
and hopefully there's there's you know
like bigger and brighter things ahead
ahead for me but
you know like this experience will
always be so special to me and i'm going
to hold it dearly to my heart
amiko congratulations on the show and it
sucks that it's coming to an end because
it's such a great show and
the fact that my kids get to watch it
with me is it's brilliant it's a way to
bring the family together so i really
appreciate it and your storyline
love it so thank you so much really
appreciate it thank you thank you
you